hubble voilà un nom qui vous dit sans
doute quelque chose depuis une quinzaine
d'années maintenant ce télescope spatial
américain radicalement fait évoluer la
vision que nous avons de l'espace buzz
va bientôt tirer sa révérence patrick
esther nous raconte son épopée
depuis la nuit des temps l'humanité a
observé le ciel nocturne
mais dans les profondeurs du noir
seulement déchirés par les lueurs des
étoiles les hommes ne pouvaient imaginer
les couleurs et les formes des astres
dans l'histoire des découvertes
astronomiques
il y a eu beaucoup d'étapes fondamentale
la dernière d'entre elles remontent à 15
ans 24 avril 90 à bord de la navette 5
astronautes procède ce jour-là à la mise
en orbite du télescope spatial hubble
mais dès les premiers temps il faut se
rendre à l'évidence le miroir a été mal
fait et le télescope est myope
une seconde mission de réparation en
orbite doit être organisé pour lui
placer une paire de lunettes
dès la réception des premiers clichés
il a été clair que ces lunettes avait
totalement corriger les défauts et
depuis quasiment chaque mois de
nouvelles images spectaculaires ont
permis aux astronomes mais aussi au
grand public de percer les mystères de
la vie et de la mort des étoiles grâce à
d'autres documents les scientifiques ont
pu étudier les collisions entre des
galaxies est reconstituée par ordinateur
c'est choc d'une violence inouïe qui
donne naissance à de nouvelles étoiles
une collision comme celle que connaîtra
notre propre voie lactée mais dans des
milliards d'années heureusement en 94
le bbl a été braquée vers une portion du
ciel
apparemment vide après plusieurs jours
de pose sa caméra a pu enregistrer les
confins de l'univers à 12 milliards
d'années-lumière de noeux des galaxies
formées juste après le big bang originel
l'instrument a pu nous prouver que
l'expansion de l'univers continuera sans
fin
a pu vérifier également la théorie
d'einstein sur la propagation de la
lumière et les mirages gravitationnelle
pourtant ses succès à grand spectacle
n'ont pas permis jusqu'ici d'assurer la
survie de ce télescope dont la mission
devrait s'arrêter en 2007
à cette date un remorqueur automatique
viendra lui accrocher un moteur pour
freiner sa vitesse et déclenché sa chute
contrôlée dans l'océan où un nombre
astronomique de débris